my first round I was 51 Strokes over par
okay so if like par 72 I was like 121.
and so I was like
over the next lifetime I'm gonna get
Shay 51 Strokes off be a scratch golfer
and then from there my dream is to go
pro I love what I do so much like I love
working at Barstool so much I love
traveling around making my videos I
realize maybe this is attainable in
terms of if I really did and I have
different resources than everyone else
probably has if they're trying to go
after this like I knew people who were
like the top Chris Como who's like Tiger
Woods Golf coach yeah was like working
with me wow but because of Barstool and
just good networking and like I had
something to offer him too and of of a
platform so
I had I was sponsored by uh TaylorMade
and G4 like G4 is my clothing sponsor
and Taylor it was my club sponsor so you
were all ready to be on the tour I was
honestly I did make I was Pro because I
was getting paid to be sucky yeah but um
so I had like way more resources so if I
think and I have like a
I'm not a great athlete but I'm like a
good enough athlete where I think I'm
I'm past a threshold of what you have to
be to be a professional golfer
and I do think I have the mind for it
but I realize you have to do this every
single day and you can't I couldn't make
videos traveled done any stuff I love to
do that the lifestyle that I worked so
hard to get to I worked so hard to get
to the lifestyle that I love and I was
gonna have to just like cancel it out to
just play golf every day and I was like
it's not it's not worth it to me I'd
rather just be a dream
well it's it's interesting because
you're kind of living one dream yeah
it's hard to dream jump
that's kind of what I realized and it
sounds so obvious but I was like dude
I'm already living a dream why am I
going to cancel out something no I
already have to go from I might not get
I could break my back and just have that
neither thing
yeah dude oh that'd be the worst bro if
you were do they have any wheelchair
guys on the PGA tour they have a dude
who is he's on the PGA but his name is
Jake Olson he played Long Snapper at USC
Southern Cal and he's blind oh wow and
bro he is I think he's like a I want to
say he's like a seven handicap he's like
he's amazing at golf he plays with his
dad his dad goes out there puts the ball
down oh tells him how many yards it is
lines him up to the to the shot and he
smacks it damn I might have lied about
his handicap he is technically
handicapped though
but dude he's and he's an awesome guy
and that that's an accomplishment bro
people are like hey what's your handicap
but he's like oh handicapped
blind yeah all of it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one